hey guys it's Jan here as you know I
really enjoyed the Deadpool movie and
I'm psyched to hear that sequels already
been greenlit and is being written by
the same screenwriters in this video I'm
going to break down Deadpool's
post-credit scenes and talk about what
it means for the sequel there will be
spoilers ahead so if you're not ready
for that check out my non-spoiler review
of the movie right here
Deadpool's post credits are the perfect
mix of tribute to John Hughes's classic
80s comedy Ferris Bueller's Day Off and
sliding marvels post credits scenes
which typically tease future
installments in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and a featured samuel l.jackson
as a leather clad eyepatch wearing
shield director Nick Fury at the end of
Iron Man Thor and Captain America the
First Avenger
Deadpool's joke that oh you're expecting
a teaser for Deadpool 2 well we don't
have that kind of money again it's a
crack at not only Marvel's movies but
also other big-budget pg-13 superhero
movies such as the x-men franchise and
the influence of Ferris Bueller is
obvious in the look of Deadpool's
post-credits in which our antihero Danza
Bueller style dressing gown and appears
in a room which owes a lot to the
classic comedy thanks to the positioning
of its two doors the pictures on the
wall and its flowery wallpaper and it's
also clear in Deadpool's fourth wall
breaking line you still here
it's over go home and later also tells
us to go all of which mimics Ferris
Bueller's words as does the way Deadpool
says them while emerging from the door
and walking towards the camera and when
Deadpool says took Attica at the very
end he's imitating the same sound which
appears at the end of Ferris Bueller's
post credits that's taken from yellow
song oh yeah okay so in the second part
of Deadpool's post credits we get the
reveal that there's going to be a sequel
featuring the comic book character cable
Deadpool playfully mentions that they're
looking to cast someone a big guy with a
flat top like Mel Gibson Dolph Lundgren
or Keira Knightley it's interesting that
Deadpool mentions Mel Gibson because the
cover of Deadpool 41 it's a fantastic on
March 2 the original Mad Max trilogy in
which Mill Gibson of course played Max
and the score - the Deadpool movie is by
junkie XL who also scored Mad Max fury
road as the Dolph Lundgren he played The
Punisher in the 1989 movie and the
Punisher has appeared in the Deadpool
suicide Kings comics the keira knightley
reference as well as being a joke about
her acting range could
to be a crafty callback to the fact that
she played bounty hunter Domino Harvey
in Tony Scott's 2005 action movie Domino
and in the Marvel Comics is a female
mutant called Domino who teams up with
cables mercenary group six-pack by the
way dead pulls words big secret reminded
me of the characters appearance in the
post-credits of x-men origins Wolverine
where we see his severed head breaking
the fourth wall whispering Shh to the
audience because at the time no one
knows he's still alive there have been
rumors and support from fans for a good
while now about having cable in the
sequel cables the son of Cyclops and
Jean Grey clone Madeline prior he's a
time-traveling mutant cyborg with a
cybernetic eye Bionic arms superhuman
strength and telepathic and telekinetic
powers when Deadpool and cable first
meet their enemies but later they team
up and even have their own comic book
series together in the comics cable also
established the x-force basically an
offshoot of the x-men so making a sequel
with him might be a good way for Fox to
finally get an x-force movie off the
ground Ryan Reynolds has already said
that an x-force movie is a priority for
him and Reynolds also posted a teaser
video of him and Olivia Munn who plays
psylocke in x-men apocalypse so if he
hinting at a potential Deadpool Psylocke
video in x-force what do you think going
back to character arcs that were left
open in Deadpool for me I'd love to see
Vanessa get to play her Quickbook
alter-ego copycats in the final fight
vanessa was put in a glass case like the
one wave was in at the workshop and a
jack started suffocating her just as
he'd done to trigger Wade's mutant
powers as Ajax told Wade earlier in the
movie stress activates mutant genes so
perhaps the stress of falling off an
exploding Helicarrier in the glass tank
could have triggered some powers in
Vanessa that we'll see in the next movie
in the comics her metamorphic powers are
so strong that she can replicate it at
the mutant abilities and their
appearance so she could be a really
interesting character to have in the
x-men universe and what about Cunningham
the other patient that way talk to her
age axis workshop well it's interesting
that the film didn't explicitly seem to
kill him off as I think I saw him being
injected encased up by angel dust later
in the movie perhaps Ajax was telling
him as a super soldier or mutant to
someone and will see his character come
back what do you think and remember that
Colossus tells Deadpool that we'll make
an x-man
of you yet so perhaps we'll see Deadpool
pop up in a future x-men movie or maybe
a gambit or Wolverine movie even now
garrison Kane was in the original
screenplay for Deadpool but ended up
getting Kurt to do to the movies tight
budget garrison Kane has huge Bionic
arms and the filmmakers thought the
additional visual effects required would
be too expensive but the character does
fit him well with cable and x-force in
the comics so it would be interesting to
see if he makes it into a sequel by the
way Deadpool director Tim Miller has
said he loved to see Deadpool fight
Wolverines female clone x-23 after all
there was that funny moment in the movie
where Deadpool had a moment true moral
quandary about attacking some female
goons debating outloud whether it is
more sexist not to hit them than
actually to hit them before I got bored
and pulled out his gun pitting deadpool
against a female wolverine would also
get around the fact that hugh jackman
said he wants the next Wolverine movie
to be his last so guys what did you
think of the post-credits tease and who
would you like to see play cable in
Deadpool 2 and are there any other x-men
or other characters you'd like to see in
the sequel I can't wait to read your
comments below by the way to check out
over a hundred more Deadpool Easter eggs
and references watch my full Deadpool
Easter Egg video here and you can also
win some cool Deadpool merch on that
video too and there's also a link here
to my full Deadpool playlist with my
review core behind the scenes facts
about the movie and Comic Con panel
thanks for watching and see you next
time
you be going movie lovers
you